[Music]
our light viewing behavior has perhaps
the strongest effect on our levels of
alertness and our capacity to fall
asleep and get a good night's sleep
and this is because at the fundamental
layer of our biology
every cell in our body needs information
about time of day
it's no coincidence that
we have a collection of neurons over the
roof of our mouth the so-called
suprachiasmatic nucleus that's our
central circadian clock it informs every
cell in our body about time of day but
it is deep in our brain it has no access
to light
so there are
a collection of neurons in the eye the
so-called melanopsin ganglion cells or
sometimes called intrinsically sensitive
photosensitive ganglion cells these are
just neurons in the back of your eye
remembering of course that the eye is
actually part of the brain that's
outside the skull
and
those neurons communicate to the central
clock when it's daytime and when it's
night so the simple behavior that i do
believe everybody should adopt including
many blind people we can talk about why
that is is to view ideally sunlight for
two to ten minutes every morning upon
waking so when you get up in the morning
you really want to get bright light into
your eyes because it does two things
first of all it triggers
the timed release of cortisol a healthy
level of cortisol into your system which
acts as a wake-up signal and will
promote wakefulness and the ability to
focus throughout the day
it also starts a timer for the onset of
melatonin this sleepyness hormone or the
hormone of darkness as they say
melatonin is inhibited by light
so by viewing light first thing in the
day
you set in motion these two timers one
for wakefulness that starts immediately
and one for sleepiness that starts later
the key thing here is that people are
hearing a lot nowadays about avoiding
blue light blue light is so terrible
well it turns out that blue light is
exactly the wavelength of light that
triggers activation of these cells and
that's exactly what you want early in
the day
so people generally will say well maybe
i should just look at my computer or my
phone first thing in the day well it
turns out that these cells are
very
hard to activate early in the day and
very easy to activate at night so it's
kind of like the biology is encouraging
us if you will to take on the right
behaviors which are to get outside even
if there's cloud cover there's a lot
more light energy a lot more photons
coming through cloud cover than you're
going to get off your phone or a
computer and early in the day two to ten
minutes outside without sunglasses
is going to be really beneficial for a
huge range of biological functions and
brain state i have made a practice i'm
in the middle of nowhere in the country
right now of of getting up and not
necessarily doing a full workout but
just jumping rope for literally two to
five minutes two to ten minutes
outside facing
the sun where the sun is perfect and
there's certainly an effect i mean i am
moving so there's an effect on cortisol
and as you noted it's like cortisol gets
this ridiculously bad rap across the
board and it's like guys if you don't
have cortisol you're dead so exactly if
you like having
storing glycogen and breaking it down
into glucose and so on you it's
important to have some cortisol there's
a tremendous for me
mood elevating effect of this exposure
and i'm just i really have never
familiarized myself with
the mechanism by which that would be the
case and certainly if it's placebo i'm
happy to just take placebo but do you
have any explanation for why that
exposure can have such a mood elevating
effect yeah it's definitely not placebo
that morning light exposure is going to
also trigger the activation of dopamine
release you know dopamine being this
essentially feel good neuromodulator the
best way to conceptualize dopamine is
that yes it's part of the reward system
but it's really the molecule of
motivation
and positive anticipation that's really
what it's about and i should mention
that the cortisol is going to be
released in a pulse once every 24 hours
no matter what that's coming as we call
it's an intrinsic rhythm but you can
time it by viewing light and or by
getting exercise early in the day
there are actually data to just kind of
emphasize what happens when you don't do
this
there are really nice data from my
colleague david spiegel's lab he
actually co-published this with the
great bob sapolsky a few years ago
david's our associate chair of
psychiatry at stanford
and they showed that if that cortisol
pulse shows up later in the day and
especially if it's around 8 or 9 pm
then it's associated with depression by
shifting that cortisol pulse earlier in
the day you
ameliorate some of the symptoms of
depression and because of the dopamine
release you get this overall mood
enhancement there are four things that
really time our circadian biology and
these mood mechanisms properly and align
us for sleep and they the most powerful
time keeper as they say zeitgeber
because germans discovered this
mechanism initially so the most powerful
time keeper
that's there it is i knew you'd do it
better than i would
is is light when you view light and
light is the most powerful stimulus for
your biology and central circadian clock
then
it's exercise so it's your protocol of
jumping rope facing the sun you're
layering on time keepers you're giving
more signals to the central clock and
the rest of your body about when to be
active and you're also indirectly
signaling when you will want to be
asleep later then it's feeding i know a
lot of people fast through the early
part of the day now that's very
fashionable and i do that as well but
were you to
eat early in the day that can also help
and then the other one is social cues
so
interacting with people early in the day
or with your dog early in the day i have
a dog live alone with my dog so that's
how i interact with the world socially
but those things are going to create
wake up signals and your body will start
to anticipate them and your brain will
start to anticipate them such that if
you miss it for a day you're still going
to wake up and feel that alertness
signal early in the day so this is not
something that you have to do every day
but ideally you do it every day because
it's like setting a clock or a watch
properly and i should mention that for
people that live in areas with very
dense cloud cover you can use light
boxes and things of that sort but
irrespective of that in the morning and
during the day and anytime you want to
be alert you want to flip on as many
overhead lights as possible this is
because these cells in the eye that
trigger activation and alertness of the
rest of the brain and nervous system
reside in the lower portion of the eye
they view the upper visual field
now the inverse of all this is also
important
as you approach the evening or night
time and you want to go to sleep that is
a time to start avoiding bright lights
of any color not just blue light and if
possible to place whatever lights are
present in your environment lower in
your visual field so this would be desk
lamps most people don't have floor
lighting dim the lights if you want to
wear blue blockers or do something of
that sort that's fine but i think people
have taken the blue blocker thing a
little too far by wearing them all day
that's actually going to disrupt your
circadian clocks so
in the evening you really want to avoid
bright light of any kind and again it's
an averaging if you do this every once
in a while you go to the bathroom middle
of the night or you have an emergency
and things are really bright for one
night it's not going to screw you up
however there was a paper published in
the journal cell
a few years ago by my good friend and
colleague at the national institutes of
mental health his name is samuel hattar
he's the head of the chronobiology unit
at the national institutes of mental
health and what sammer's lab
showed is that bright light exposure of
any wavelength between the hours of
about 11 pm and 4 am cause a serious
disruption in the dopamine system such
that in subsequent days
you have a disruption in a lowering of
mood difficulty in learning there's a
cascade of things that happen in other
words we get punished for light viewing
at the wrong times of the circadian
cycle and we get rewarded for light
viewing at the correct times of the
circadian cycle
you